what's going on guys welcome to another
tutorial video this would be a real
quick introduction to Amazon Web
Services uh just a couple things right
off the top Amazon is not paying me to
do this video there is no referral link
this is the website that you'll go to I
just think it's kind of cool cuz they
give you a nice little free instance
there's another website called like
Python anywhere order com
I think it's com that you can do
something similar to this but the idea
here is that you can run a single
instance for free and you can run kind
of basic Python scripts from the cloud
and then as time goes on you can
actually buy some of their processing
and I'll get more into that and probably
some future videos but right now I'm
just going to introduce you guys to this
place and how to get started real quick
it's very very simple but yet at the
same time it's really confusing so they
offer like a million services and you
just you're like what the heck do I
actually want right so anyway you'll get
to Amazon if you don't have an account
you need to sign up otherwise you can go
to your account or it'll have you like
login then you would just go to my
account console and here or you can hit
get started for free the other thing
I'll mention is I'm sorry I can't quite
remember I signed up for Amazon Web
Services a really long time ago
but I seem to recall there maybe being a
wait for them to like give you your like
access because they wanted to like
verify your billing information because
if you exceed your you know your single
instance you have to pay for that so
honestly can't remember but I think you
have to tie up your bank account with
Amazon Web Services first but I might be
wrong so just a warning anyway click on
get started for free and wait for that
once you've done that login and I
already have access to Amazon Web
service I've been here before
but as you can see you know you have
access like all of these services and
you're probably like whoa which one do I
actually want here you know like in our
case what we're going to be doing is
just using computing so
it makes sense that we would use Amazon
Elastic Compute the idea here and what
kind of draws me to Amazon is that it's
kind of like a place where you can do
cloud computing but it's also elastic in
a sense where you pay for what you use
so it's really good if you have varying
workload basically which we do at least
at Centex and so so anyway this is what
we're going to click but again my goal
here in this video is just to show you
guys a simple example of you know
running Python so we get here it tells
you a little bit about it we've already
said hey I want to do this and AWS
offers 750 hours of either Linux or
Windows Micro instances never use
Windows Micro not sure what the point of
that is but Linux that's what we're
going to be using so we'll click on this
to create a free account wait on this
probably be like you already did this
but anyway apparently that just leads to
like an infinite loop here you click
this and then it leads you right back to
that other page so in that case hit on
my account here and then just go to AWS
management console like once you
actually you know have access so click
on that and you'll find yourself here
with again you see like this massive
list of stuff that you're like ah I
don't know which one I want in our case
we want ec2 that's what we're going to
be using so you click on that and you
should have something similar to this
you don't think you'll have a key pair
and you probably would only have wanted
security group but anyway let's go ahead
and launch the instance since we have
none let's make one so launch and then
again you're given like 50 options and
for us you know what are we looking for
well we're looking for a Python and
let's see SQLite so we don't have SQLite
anything on there but this one comes
with Python my sequel which we can use
with Python so that's fine and that's
really all we're looking for so let's
just go with this first one right but
there are some that come with other
stuff you know pre-installed but again
it's a Linux instance so like this one
doesn't come with PHP pre-installed but
if you
want PHP you can just install PHP just
think of it as like it's a computer
right so anyway we'll accept 64-bit
we'll hit select no you're a little
search bar here and then we'll just hit
yeah review and launch because and
basically this yeah this is just a
really really tiny baby instance so
obviously your network performance isn't
very good they give you 500 Meg's of
memory so that's nice and then it's like
a little Raspberry Pi so you can
configure a bunch of other stuff if you
wanted but we're not going to touch that
right now you could also add storage if
you wanted but again we're not going to
touch that right now so we're going to
launch so here it says improve your
instances security basically it's open
to the world so you could edit the
security groups and you can basically
say like where you want you can add
various rules and stuff to that but
we'll get back to that anyway what
happens here is so you could say like OK
for SSH connections here's the poor and
then the source can only be you can put
in a custom IP or your own IP so that's
that but that's fine so we're just going
to go ahead and review and launch and
launch and now it's going to say either
select an existing key pair or create a
new one now what this means is basically
to connect via SSH what makes SSH secure
is that not only is the stuff
transferred over SSH secure with
encryption but also you can disable it
but SSH normally is going to require
also that you have a key that you use to
again confirm its use so just for
security so someone even if somebody got
your SSH login information wouldn't
matter they wouldn't have the key but
obviously they could get the key so
anyway we'll just choose I'm going to
choose an existing pair I already have
it but you could also create a new pair
and when you do that you'll just
download the key and then once you've
downloaded it like here we'll just do
this
well you'll download it and then I'll
show you in a second where you'll have
to put that in
and then here you'll just have to say
that yeah if you don't have that that
private key file you won't be able to
log into your instance you can also
proceed without a key pair not really
sure what the defaults of the server is
actually it might even be by default we
can check that out a little bit though
and see what the defaults are I just
want to get us started so I'm going to
choose an existing key pair but you'll
need to create a new one how many hit
launch instance and our instance is
running so now we can go view instances
and here it is this is one I terminated
this one's initializing it'll probably
be up in a little bit here so I'll just
pause and wait it usually is like up
within like a minute or something right
mine's up and running by the way it was
like you know giving this a little like
waiting thing and I just hit refresh in
it and it was ready so just for the
record if you're still sitting there
just hit refresh so then what we can do
is we can actually launch the instance
so right here just click this little box
and hit connect and that's going to pop
up here you can either connect via your
own standalone SSH client so something
like putty a putty would work or
anything else yeah it seemed it says
here connect putty for us or just to
keep it simple we're going to use their
Java SSH client and so just come up from
your browser you just have to allow it
and then down here is where you're going
to have to say you know what the key
name is and then the full path to that
key wherever that key is on your
computer that's where you want it so if
you just downloaded it you never removed
it it's going to be in your downloads
somewhere mine's in my x-files yes
that's why I called it my anyway so now
we can hit you can save the key in your
browser cache if you want so well I'm
going to go ahead and just do that so
I'll probably move this around and then
launch SSH client you'll probably get
some things like you want to use run
this you'll get that and you'll probably
another little Java box yep right here
run
and you want to add this host yeah and
probably a couple other questions come
on no that was the only one we got
anyway so you should have this window
that looks like this and you've got you
know some information here bubble blah
blah blah and then it says right here
run sudo yum update that's what we're
going to go ahead and do just for the
record you'll see this kind of stuff all
the time like sudo and Nano and all this
stuff sudo is super user do and so like
this kind of allows you to do what the
super user or like the root account
would do you have to have the ability to
do that but we're given it since it's
like the me account here and then yum
and this stands for yellow-dog updater
modified or something like that it's
very updater install stuff usually and
then update so hit enter and you'll
probably a whole bunch of stuff here
it'll say like what it's going to
download and how much space that's going
to take so here it's going to take 26
Meg's looks like we're going to download
even some stuff for Python here crypto
para me Co for SSH hopefully that's just
I guess it's installing some stuff for
this stuff anyway uh yes and so it's
going to download that and run through a
bunch of stuff mm-hmm and whenever it's
done I'll just show you guys at least
just how to access Python and and then
I'll cut off the video and then we'll
proceed with some other videos using
Python generally what I would use this
for is like being a Linux machine you
can set up like a cron job and that cron
job can run your Python files or you can
just straight up just constantly run
your Python files on here but anyway I
should be able to Python and now you can
see right here uh it's like the typical
Python text right in our case we're
using I think it's two points yeah two
point six point nine so we might decide
to update that to two point seven but
anyway just for kicks we can do you know
hello it does hello and did you do the
typical define of funds and then tab
over print hello done and then call
farms prints out hello you get the idea
if anybody's been following my tutorials
I never coded in the prompt thing like
this but yeah when you define a function
you're going to have to automatically do
your tabs so it goes dot dot dot you
would tab it over
type what you want and then when you're
done with that function you would just
double enter and it takes you out of
that function and then you can call it
so anyways that's the basics of Amazon
Web Services getting set up getting a
simple instance running it's absolutely
free so you might as well do it toy
around with it anyways you can do a lot
of cool stuff with this and it's kind of
a way to run your applications in the
cloud and allow them to scale and then
eventually you know we can hook up
Python to my sequel and start running
some pretty epic applications in the
cloud so anyway if that sounds
interesting you guys stay tuned and if
it does sound interesting to you guys I
suggest that you be prepared to shell
out money to continue playing with this
because probably pretty pretty quickly
you'll be charged I'm not sure how how
much we can do with this ec2 thing
before it's like hey pay up but we'll
find out anyway hopefully you guys
enjoyed as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support of the
subscriptions and until next time